do you accept
personal responsibility for defeat in
north shropshire last night do you
acknowledge that that vote
against the conservative party was
because of you
clearly the voting
in north shropshire is a is a very
disappointing result and
i i
totally understand people's frustrations
i i hear
what the the voters are saying in north
shropshire and uh in all humility i've
got to
accept uh that that verdict yes sam and
uh what i would say is of course i i
understand that what voters want us as
the government to be doing at all times
is to is to focus on them and on on
their priorities and my job as prime
minister is to get the focus on to the
stuff that really matters to to all of
us so
not just the the the vaccine rollout
getting boosted now but what we're doing
to fight crime to sort out our borders
with the borders bill the human rights
act and what we're doing uh to to keep
the economy going got the fastest
growing economy in europe more jobs now
than there were before uh the pandemic
began what we're doing to train up our
our country and uh
and prepare our our economy for what i
hope will be a great recovery but you
know i i totally understand uh why
people were
frustrated and are frustrated uh in
north shropshire
i think viewers would have just heard
you not
accept personal
responsibility and said deflect with a
list of other things your government is
doing so can i try that
perfectly you you accept you are to
blame look i i i'm responsible for
everything that the
government does and of course i take it
so what's a personal response so what
things that went wrong
under your watch that your
responsibility are partly to blame for
instance do you think the absolutely
cavalier approach to lockdown rules by
you and your staff in downing street
played a part in last night's defeat
i think that people are
frustrated and i understand that
uh what the
basically what's been going wrong sam is
that
the
in the last few weeks
some things have been going very well
but what the the
people have been hearing what people
have been hearing is just a constant uh
litany of stuff about
politics and politicians and
stuff that isn't about them and isn't
about the things that we can do uh to
make life better and so to that extent
uh of course you're right and i think
that the the
the job
of the government is to make people like
you sam uh interested in uh the booster
rollout and in and in skills and in in
housing and in everything else that were
that we're doing and unfortunately
you're totally right we haven't been
able
to get the focus on those issues so
prime minister it sounds to me like
you're quite clearly blaming the public
for being focused on the wrong thing and
the media for reporting the wrong thing
so can i try again
i think the following are responsible i
think it's very important this is what
tory mps are saying to us so forgive me
this is what your colleagues believe do
you believe uh that uh
you trying to change the sleaze rules
in favor of you and your colleagues
which triggered the by-election which
caused this defeat do you accept hand up
hands up responsibility for that yeah i
i do because i think i think it's like
it goes back to exactly what i was just
saying sandwich i think it it comes into
the overall category of politics of
politicians talking about
ourselves and those issues
and and seeming
to be focused on those
issues at the expense of the things that
really matter to to people and so i
think my job is to
get over what we're we're doing more
effectively and uh to show people that
as a result of the fastest vaccine
rollout and the fastest booster rollout
in in europe that we've got more jobs
than before the pandemic began and i've
got to you know put my hands up and say
did have have i failed to get that
message across in the last few weeks has
it been obscured by all this other stuff
yes i'm afraid
it has so what needs to change given it
was your advisors laughing on video
about breaking covered rules you got a
tory donor to pay for the refurbishment
of your flat
how do you stop those things happening
again that's the question tories are
asking yes i know but can i just if just
with all humility in respect to you sam
those questions are exactly the kind of
uh questions about politics and
politicians and
all those kinds of things
the running of uh of government
uh that i'm gonna i'm gonna have to fix
of course but
the real issue that i think people want
to focus on is what we're doing uh to
sort out the uh the nhs the investment
that we're putting in to get us through
a very tough time and what we're doing
to tackle the pandemic and that is the
number one priority for the government
because if i may say
respectfully omicron is a if i can move
on to that for a second omicron is a is
a very
serious threat to us now we are seeing a
considerable wave coming through
and
people have got to be uh prepared and
they've got to understand what it
entails
and that's why the best thing everybody
can do is not just follow the the
guidance advice that we've we've set out
but get boosted now that is the the
crucial thing that we need to do we've
we've now as of yesterday
vaccinated 25 million people with a
booster
which is a a
great number but we need to do a lot
more and
we've got the
everybody's coming forward to help
you've got the army here uh
giving you massive assistance you've got
volunteers the teams are expanding the
whole time we have the capacity uh to
deliver uh the get boosted in our
campaign what we need is for people to
realize the urgency and come forward
themselves prime minister tory mps say
the dysfunction of your
administration is having real world
consequences about exactly what you're
talking about for instance your cabinet
ministers are contradicting your
scientific advisors um over the rules
and over the guidance should people be
kept should people be cancelling
social events in the run-up to christmas
yes or no well i i've said uh already
that
people should be cautious and but what
we've also said is that people should
decide what they want to do it's a
matter for their personal choice we're
not closing things down but we do think
people need to be cautious and and you
can see that further encourages people
to prioritize just what they absolutely
say is he right yeah look i think what
both chris and i chris whittie and i are
saying
is that there is a big wave of omicron
coming through people need to be prudent
uh they need to think about you know you
need to think about your your budget of
of risk as it were
sam but what we're not saying we're not
in the position that we were in last
year of closing everything down and
trying to mandate exactly what people do
we want to leave much more to people's
responsibility and choice but we want
them to be aware
of the facts and the facts are that
omicron it does represent a very
considerable risk and people need to be
aware of that risk they need to take the
steps and above all they need to get
boosted now final question tory mps are
saying publicly that conversations have
begun
about your future whether you should
stay in that job
if it was in the interests of the
country if it was in the interest of the
conservative party would you resign can
i just remind you everything i've been
saying throughout this interview which
is that is exactly the kind of question
that qualifies that breaks the golden
rule what we're focusing on is getting
the job done what we're focusing on is
trying to make sure that we not only
have the fastest vaccine uh roller in
europe the fastest booster rollout as
we've already done but that we're able
because of the get boosted now campaign
to avert some of the uh more damaging
consequences of omicron that is what the
government is engaged in doing now that
is what i am focused on and do you know
what i think that is what people would
want me to be focused on right now